montrer l'image du jour l'image du jour
cette scène est magnifique elle s'est
déroulée sur la plage de ouistreham co2
dans le calvados en normandie numéro 14
merci voilà il se réveille lui il y aura
lieu l'année prochaine voiture de police
municipale s'est embourbé dans le sable
et de nombreux jeunes sont venus à aider
les forces de l'ordre ils ont poussé la
voiture pour la désensabler regarder ça
c'est notre sondage du jour
c'est magnifique c'est parti voila voila
moi ça ça je trouve ça fort c'est très
court mais je voulais absolument vous le
montrer après on a ce qu'on entend
tellement de choses en ce moment oui moi
on entend tellement de choses sur les
vrais surtout voilà n'importe quoi que
les jaunes ils s'entendent pas
catholique et rue je vais vous dire
voilà et c'est pas vrai il ya plein de
gestes comme ça et il ya plein de 2,2 de
politique sur ton très bien avec des
jeunes et donc voilà on parlait des
cités on va reparler avec un média
jordan avec sequeira jeudi cd je vous
dis c'est pas parce que c'est pas pareil
partout et il ya des bons des deux côtés
de surat qu'il ya des bons et des
mauvais des deux côtés on peut pas dire
les jeunes de banlieue ils sont tous
pourris alors que c'est pas vrai du tout
je peux vous dire pour 90 % ils sont
formidables et ils sont tous voila je me
dis bah voilà ils sont ici s'ils sont
sur l'ice vous dis j'essaie de faire des
choses
il essaie d'avancer 10 et gagner leur
vie il essaie d'aider les autres est-ce
que vous dire qu'il ya une solidarité en
banlieue qui est exceptionnel je vous
dis dans les cités il ya une solidarité
avait pendant le cas exceptionnel voilà
je vous dis donc faut arrêter de dire
des jeunes de banlieue un sont
dégueulasses ils sont si son ca et de
l'autre côté
et bah forcément aussi dans la police à
90% aussi zhang à 10% de mecs qui font
n'importe quoi et qui font des bavures
et qui se prennent pour des autres qui
se prennent pour des cow boys en
achetant lama après voilà et ccc mejhoul
dit le gros du gros c'est comme à
l'époque des gilets jaunes moi j'étais
mieux au créneau aussi jeter monté au
créneau parce que c'était devenu au bout
d'un moment les gilet jaune c'est tout
ce dépouillement des gilets jaunes à 95
% cu des mecs qui veulent s'en sortir et
qui essaie de se battre pour s'en sortir
et pour essayer de de pouvoir vivre
jusqu'à la fin du mois
correctement et après il ya 5 %
d'abrutis qui sont là pour casser qui
met un gilet jaune et qui se dit j'ai
les jaunes mais juste pour aller casser
des boutiques et pour aller faire les
comptes pour faire chier mais je vous
dis mais sinon 95% des filets jaunes ils
sont là justement pour vous
pour nous et pour essayer de faire
avancer les choses et ils ont quand même
fait avancer à pas mal les choses
s'arrêtent au sein forçant d'abrutis qui
font n'importe quoi voilà c'est ça et
c'est ça qui me rend fou